[Music]
brothers and sisters
you got the three muslims here t3n
and for today's podcast we're going to
be getting into why
islam i'll let romney start it off
why islam
logically speaking why islam
why not why not islam
no but foreign i'm just saying no on a
real note
so why islam if there is
a god in religion right let's we
established last time there was a god
right
if you don't believe in god you have no
reason to and i challenge everybody to
bring a reason to any of us
why you don't believe in god there is no
reason logically
so let's say there is a god now okay
let's say
is there a religion yes or no you would
have to look up the religions in the
world
but you wouldn't have to look at all of
them necessarily because let's look at
the bigger ones let's look at judaism
it's an ethnocentric religion which
means you would have to ethnically be
jewish maternally on your mother's side
to even be allowed in the religion
otherwise it's a very very long and hard
process
then you have hinduism and sikhism these
are regional religions
go ahead go ahead no no go on go on what
no i was just saying pause because you
said long and hard
go on continue to continue though so
it's a very long hard drawn-out process
all right so yeah to to be uh
to be man you were cool but yeah go on
bro
i lost my train of thought man no no
you're good you're gonna say i don't
know bro you were on
something real you said that um
when for judaism you'd have to be born
into it
and if not then it's a very drawn out
process let me correct that
pattern of speech there so we don't get
lost in the same thing again
all right yeah so to be uh religiously
jewish you must be ethnically jewish as
well
then you look at sikhism and hinduism
these are both regional religions
right so it's it's almost as if they're
not really asking people to come and
accept it right you're born into it or
you're not
at the end of the day and even uh
hinduism
or sorry sikhism they believe that all
ways are correct which is
impossible yes that's completely
impossible yeah because you have
completely
opposite and opposing ideas like
literally christianity will say islam is
not right and islam will say
christianity is not right
they cannot both be correct it's
illogical um
i just want to apologize there's nothing
wrong with respecting all walks of life
but they can't all be correct yes 100
100 and then you have
two more basically you have islam well
actually let me get buddhism out the way
buddhism does not deal with god
therefore it cannot be from god now you
have islam in christianity
islam calls people to come and accept it
and it tells his followers to preach and
give what we call dawa teaching people
about islam
christianity tells people to preach the
message to preach the gospel and tell
people to come and
accept jesus as the lord and savior so
on and so forth so you have two options
left
and there are two strategies with this
you can
disqualify one which qualifies the other
and then look into it or you can qualify
one which would disqualify the other
for example if you come to the
conclusion that christianity is
absolutely true
then islam would just be gone because if
christianity is absolutely true
then islam cannot be absolutely true
like we said two opposing ideas cannot
both be true at the same time
but if you qualify islam 100 then
christianity would have to go
because same reason so either or works
if you look at christianity which uh
angel you started off as a christian
correct
catholic catholic okay but i i did run
the christian path
yeah must have been a long hard journey
bro
pause pause or continue continue
so you would have one or the other
so if you look into islam which is what
we're basically going to be doing
throughout this episode insha'allah
we will come to the conclusion that
islam is without a doubt
if a religion is true it would
definitely be islam
we could talk about christianity i don't
want to you know throw straight on
anything or any
scripture or any belief system but
christianity
just from the get go really make sense
and i'm just going to summarize it with
this circular reasoning
so god creates man and from man comes
woman
and then we have this long line of you
know generations
generations and no god coming down
incarnation trinity none of that until
we get to jesus
and then all of a sudden woman gives
birth to god
who god created right gives birth to god
and then
god is murdered by man to save man
from god's punishment as the sacrifice
and it's just this giant
circular reasoning circular argument
that doesn't really make sense
and on top of that they're gonna argue
that
this one god that's always been one god
in one person
all of a sudden is three in one and it's
i was gonna make a joke i'm not gonna
make that joke but all of a sudden
they're coming out and saying no no i'm
actually three in one
right i'm not one uni personal god i'm a
triune god
this doesn't really make sense because
even in the bible it says god is not the
author of confusion
so why all of a sudden you're doing this
back and forth and even if you read the
bible jesus never teaches the trinity
every time okay i'll just summarize it
with this a jewish man came and asked
jesus
what is the most important commandment
he said hear o israel your lord god is
one worshiping with all your heart your
soul your mind
he this would be the perfect time to
teach the trinity listen i'm the son of
god literally i'm gonna die for your
sins and there's a holy spirit
there's a father and we're three in one
and he never says this
when he's directly asked he doesn't say
it so
and we can see that the ambiguity
throughout christian history so on and
so forth
and this is not the hate on christianity
this is just my findings
when i looked into it because yes i did
look into it and i find that it is just
not founded in the bible
and the bible itself it does not seem to
be authentic or authoritative
as a historical text for many reasons
and it's basically
scholarly consensus that it has not been
preserved
it has not been it's not infallible it's
not inerrant
it has been changed and um i can quote
scholars if people want to hear that but
it's basically scholarly consensus at
this point so that just leaves us there
i got two questions
before you even ask the question what
was that joke
i was going to say all of a sudden god
no i can't man because no it's haram
it's i can't make that joke
no i can't well this whole like man-made
i guess concept of trinitarian as i'm
just saying
it wasn't even in the old testament not
at all
not at all well i want you to go into
that and the second thing is islamically
speaking
jesus or islam was sent here
to spread a message
to a specific time and at a specific
place
not to be some universal message yes
right yes 100 yes and this is even
mentioned in the bible
as it says in the bible that jesus said
i did not come from anyone except for
the loss of israel or i only came for
the lost sheep of israel which means
it's only coming to the jews
so who went to the gentiles the non-jews
paul did
paul never met jesus paul never met
jesus
and all of a sudden he's preaching these
things that jesus never preached
dying for sins and he is literally the
son of god in the trinity
and this that the other where is this
coming from it's coming from a man who
never met
jesus who didn't even preach to people
who had knowledge of the scripture he
preached to
non-jews who didn't know the bible who
didn't know
uh what the prophets of the past have
written and what has been
uh put in the oath or in the torah so
completely with all due respect to
christians
in my humble opinion completely
fabricated on paul's part
um and then we have the matter of the
trinity in the old testament
even james white who was a christian
scholar himself a highly respected
christian scholar he says that
if you're going to look for the trinity
don't look for in the old testament
because it's not there
and the only way for me to really go in
depth on it is to try
and use one of their arguments and
counteract it so
god is called elohim in the old
testament
and elohim is actually the plural word
for god's
multiple gods and they say see it says
let and it uses terms like let us create
man in our image
right and that's like oh plural there's
multiple hebrews right
that's in hebrew yes but that's
translated to english and elohim
is a word for god like i mentioned that
is
actually plural which means multiple
gods but when you add
i am basically to the end of a word or
end of a name or something in hebrew
it's actually for respect for example
muhammadim
right that's in the bible and it means
the beloved one and when you add
when you add the im sound at the end
it's basically
saying like out of respect or majesty or
something like that of that matter
we would consider it the royal perhaps
they didn't use that terminology
but regardless it's to basically say god
is god in full sense of the word
because you have verses that say the god
of gods and it literally says elohim of
elohim
so you have two possible translations
multiple gods
or one god in the full sense of the word
and
how do we differentiate between the two
one is talking about one god alone
the noun or the name elohim
is plural but the verb is singular for
example create
or bestow or send or something
these verbs would be singular
while the name elohim is plural making
god one
and the christians look at it and say oh
since it's plural it's the trinity
but this actually doesn't make sense
because elohim would mean multiple gods
not multiple people inside a god it
would mean multiple gods
so you would either have to concede to
the fact that trinity is just
polytheism and believing in multiple
gods or you would have to drop this
argument
which most christians nowadays i would
say they have dropped it because it is a
very weak argument
and most of the christian scholars don't
go there anymore because they know that
it doesn't make sense
yeah let me let me chime in here right
so
the trinity claims that it's all the
same thing
that the father uh the holy spirit
and jesus are all the same thing it's
all god
which doesn't make sense i just
logically
anyone in their logical mind will say
that that doesn't make sense right
and when i was into christianity let me
show y'all
all right let me just repeat this so in
the bible in john 14 28
it says you heard that i said
to you i go away and i will come to you
if you love me
you would have rejoiced because i go to
the father for the father is greater
than i
if the father is greater than i
well then that means that the father is
god and jesus is not
yeah subhan allah there's no way for
them to be equal if one is greater
this is the verse that christian church
fathers
struggled with for centuries i would say
because it's so clearly against
what they believe but nonetheless
it is in their scripture so subhanallah
i don't want to spend the entire session
just ripping christianity
okay so the ebs were one group of people
that didn't believe that jesus was god
or the literal son of god they believed
he was
a man messenger i believe they believed
he was a messiah as well
but they did not believe he was the god
or son of god um
i would say the same is uh the same goes
for many of his disciples they didn't
seem to believe he was god either the
only one making the distinction would be
paul who never met jesus
um but yeah the ibianites uh we don't
have much on them all we have is from
their enemies people who hated them
and called them heretics and and all
this stuff
so basically all we know about it is
they existed very early on they existed
before the gospel of john was even
written
and they believed that jesus was just a
man messenger and messiah
if jesus so explicitly clearly without a
doubt said that he is the son of god
and their trinity is true how come the
ebi and i didn't believe in it
how come there were groups of people
before that were deemed heretics by the
church fathers later on
which is basically eventually just came
the the biggest uh
contender so to speak so that i would
say the truth kind of just whittled away
over time because the falsehood had
power over them
but nonetheless if it was so clear how
come there are people like ibia and i
said i didn't believe in it
i agree 100 man god was also powerful
and
and you know why would he come down in
human form in the form of his creation
to subject himself to the punishment of
his creation just to prove a point that
he's now going to die for all of our
sins he doesn't need to prove anything
yeah a lot of a lot of the time i hear
christians say things like
god you know came down to our level and
i'm like that doesn't
like that doesn't even make sense right
god can never be down on our level
because we are dependent creatures god
is independent to be down on our level
he would have to be
he would have to give up being god one
and especially if you say he's 100
human that doesn't make sense um and
i think we should finish off with this
point because this is basically
one of the biggest irrefutable points
the idea that god can do
anything now people misuse the term
thing or anything because when you say
anything
people generally think anything i can
think of or anything i can utter
like a squared circle but that's not
actually true for example
can god make a barren woman who
has given birth this is impossible not
because god is weak
but because the terms are completely
contradiction uh
completely contradictory meaning that if
you've given birth
by the definition of the term you've
given birth you cannot be barren
but if you're a barren you cannot give
birth
so it's like can god make a squared
circle he can't and not because he's
weak but because it's not a possible
reality within this universe
so baron is uh would you define baron as
in this situation
yeah so so and and the second analogy i
gave her in the the first one
uh the one with a woman yeah so baron
means
just like infertile yeah she cannot give
birth
she cannot conceive she cannot give
birth so
you cannot have a woman who is barren
that has given birth you cannot have a
square
that is a circle and this is not because
god is weak he can't do anything it's
because the question itself is a fallacy
the question itself doesn't make sense
that's like me
saying a woman who has no children who's
never had children
how many kids does she have does she
have five or three
does you have five kids or three kids
like what the hell are you going on
about it's like when people ask who is
the father of jesus he doesn't have a
father
that's an illogical question so to say
that god
became man and was a 100 man and 100 god
that is like me saying 2 plus 2 is 11.
it just doesn't make sense that's like
me saying
um this square is a circle
it's just and it's not yeah no brother i
haven't
i haven't read into this part too much
but
abraham's wife was she infertile
or was she just like kind of old and
just you know having a little trouble
she she was
she uh i believe was barren for some
time she was she was not able to to
conceive and eventually
god blessed them uh with a child despite
being old
um the bible and quran have different
stories the bible says that
uh so what you're saying there
is the bible
like what her being blessed by god
the both both both both okay yeah but
i'm not saying she's fully barren it's
because they both reached old age and
they were having trouble but they wanted
a child
um but the the term baron is she cannot
give birth
period point-blank period um yeah
and my point is if she's barren she
can't give birth if she's
if she gives birth she's no longer
barren so you can't have both at once
that's the point
okay okay yeah i get it i get it yeah
yeah
all right confusions or misconceptions
people might have at this moment in time
islam still believes in jesus christ we
don't we're not
anti-jesus we don't believe he never
existed we do believe he existed but
and we love him too it just we believe
he was a messenger of god peace be upon
him we don't believe him to be
god we also believe in mother mary right
it's like
she was one of the greatest uh women in
islam and in history
like women wear the hijab um whatever
you see
muslim girls wear just because we're
modeling they're modeling her
right that's where they got it they're
all
wonderful people we just don't worship
them
yeah subhanallah subhanallah and if you
see
throughout history like with things like
because you mentioned mother mary or
like where the hijab basically
peace be upon her you see things like
jesus praying by putting his face to the
floor
and you see this with all the israelite
prophets in the bible
they prayed with their head on the floor
so we are just continuing
this tradition that god has put upon the
upon the people to pray to him in sajdud
in prostration with their head to the
floor
so it's nothing new this is what islam
says so without further ado i think we
should get into why islam specifically
because so far
at this point we should just title the
episode why not christianity because
we've been talking about that so much
all right all right let me let me throw
something out here and we'll run off
that
okay all right so why islam
specifically all right so i'm gonna go
as far as to say and by no means am i
saying i'm 100 corrected this is just me
uh throwing my own insight and we're
gonna run with it we're gonna play with
it let's see what happens on
i believe that god has been trying to
talk to
humans since the beginning of time
since the beginning of everything here
and it's like
it's like the telephone game we've
talked about this where it's like you're
playing the telephone game as a kid
and you say one thing you're saying oh
um
i want a banana and then by the time it
gets to you
it's saying something real nasty and
you're just like well i did not say that
like what's going on here and that's
what's happening and i feel like once
someone messes up the message
god's like all right well i can't give
you the message because you've already
proven
that you can't you can't transmit the
message you can't even
uh receive the message and then transmit
it appropriately so why should i even
continue so he goes on to the next
person
and if you look at all the religions if
you look at all the cultures if you look
at everything
they all have similarities and then it's
like when you start looking into them
even more you see
that like once the similarities
cut off that's it then
whatever it is whatever religion
whatever culture whatever philosophy or
idea is going on here it's like it
becomes very complex
and i know you guys know that like when
we don't truly understand something
we tend to complicate it we tend to like
add all these crazy things
to like i don't know create this amazing
idea that like all connects perfectly
when it's like
if you know the truth you can explain it
very simply
and if you look at islam islam is
explained
very simply it's not complicated it's
very simple
and um the thing that i wanted to get at
here
right it's because you said that
buddhism they don't even believe in god
they don't even believe in god but now
you have buddhists who actually are
starting to say oh well
maybe there is a god yeah so
it's not necessarily that they would
claim actively or the religion says god
doesn't exist
it's more so that the religion just does
not speak about god as much it's it's
more
so how you live your life you know the
story of buddha
he lived a very rich life he lived very
poor life he found something in the
middle basically
and he you know he lives a very um
content life that's basically the moral
of the story
um you know amen actually i was uh
speaking the jorgen podcast um there was
one guy on there and he
uh i saw a little clip and he was saying
that uh basically talking about
contentment happiness and desires and
stuff he said
you know a healthy man will want a
hundred more things he'll desire a
hundred new things
but uh uh an unhealthy man just wants
one thing
and that's his health back right
subhanallah so it's kind of like
the more you wish for the more you're
setting yourself up to fill the less you
want you know the more content you'll
feel uh which is the beauty in being
content with whatever allah gives you
because you know that especially at the
end of the day
um but with buddha it doesn't really
have that concept it's just kind of
the first half of it of living a
mediocre and
um content life but it doesn't deal with
god which is why i would exclude this
uh from the list of possible godly
religions
yeah i would even go as far as to say
that it's just uh
it's just a philosophy yeah it's just a
way of living but it's not like
it's religion ultimately y'all it's not
the complete message
you know and in my opinion that's why i
feel
why islam is the way i'm i'm probably
saying you're wrong
islam islam
that's that's that's it man like islam
is the full message it's not leaving
anything out
versus like all these other things it
just has
little bits and pieces and it's it's not
essentially that oh
this way um
[Music]
actually let me stop myself there
because i i don't know too much
in terms of that i'll probably be
speaking out you know where but um
yeah i i i i i
agree exactly what you're talking about
and i can even say that the quran is the
only book of faith that's been
completely conserved
and preserved from when it was created
bible and other scriptures there's been
so many different
conditions yeah um just quickly want to
mention
because it is a big it is a big point uh
saying the quran is created a lot of
people would take this the wrong way
um but he does not mean we don't mean
created in the sense that like it would
create it was created at a point
right it was always with allah in his
knowledge and so on and so forth
uh because the quran is an expression of
allah's attributes right
but the quran when it was created in the
sense that it was revealed to the
prophet
over those 23 years but from that point
of being you know
of revelation till now it's been
perfectly preserved and even bart ehrman
it's actually something i have heard
about recently
even bart ehrman who's a new testament
scholar right a scholar a historian
he says the bible has been changed and
so on so forth he goes in depth on that
and but he says that the quran seems to
be faithfully
transmitted and preserved and there's he
has no issue with that
so i think that's amazing subhanallah
even a you know secular
a religious person a scholar such as bar
imam would say that about the quran that
he believes that
it's been faithfully transmitted because
it seems to be so so
now let's talk about actually why islam
is actually answer the question why
islam we haven't really talked much
about it so if i had
why islam logically speaking
man growing up in a in a society that
really
creates the division between secularism
and
religion or science and islam it's very
easy to pick one or the other
you know we can see this in i guess the
society or the system or the government
pushing us
into this mutually exclusive predicament
either you're either conservative or
you're liberal
you're either for this or you're against
this it's so black and white and i
believe like a lot of people growing up
again it's very easy for them to pick
something that's not islam
and there could be a lot of reasons for
that one they grew up in the west
where you know there's a lot of reasons
why islam is kind of demonized
we're not going to get into that right
now um they has to kind of maintain
christianity and maintain the
traditional family system right
but again growing up i was born muslim i
you know did the five daily prayers
started fasting did everything my
parents told me
but i came to a point where i was like
nah man science makes sense right you go
to school you learn about
you know all these scientific methods
and it's like okay like
religion i can't see it i can't touch it
i can't
feel it but science is there it's proven
it's it's testable
it's led to so many advancements
and then i get to a point where i come
to islam and become a believer on my own
accord
in my later life couple a couple months
not couple months like one to two years
ago
because i realized secularism science
ironically
strengthened my iman or strengthened my
belief in god there was a lot of things
in
i guess you could say medicine
embryology um because i'm a post grad
student so
you know you learn a lot of things in
the quran that 1400 years ago there's no
way
you know they could have been known at
that time so
if it was a man-made religion if it was
some something fabricated or falsified
then there's no way these things would
have been i guess talked about at that
time in the quran
now angel talks about a thing pretty
often where
you know these things were not i guess
created today
or discovered today these things were
always there it's just science
finally caught up to it and that's a
very important point because
these discoveries these advancements
they've been there
like saying that the the world or the
the planets revolve around the sun
right at the time of the quran that
wasn't the common common belief everyone
thought everything revolved around the
earth
but that was clearly stated in the quran
that everything revolved around the sun
another thing is at the time um
they thought that moonlight or the moon
had its own light it emitted its own
type of
light and radiance but the quran
specifically says that
the moonlight is a reflected light and
now we know it's light reflected from
the sun
it doesn't emit its own light right this
is the moon
um so these things it's not like they
just started doing these things when
the discoveries went down in the 18th
19th 20th century
they've always been there and they've
always been the way they are it's just
science finally validated these things
that the quran has been preaching about
1400 years ago
that at that time there's no way the
prophet muhammad would have been able to
come and i guess share these things with
us
so that's just one of the things that i
i wanted to get out there which is the
miracles in the quran
the miracles of the prophet has come
with along with a lot of different
prophecies that
that he said that will i guess
foreshadowed the end of times
which a lot of them might even go as far
as to say majority have already come
true
yeah most scholars say that uh there's
only like two left or something very
small
uh subhanallah which is um one river
i think it's it's i don't know how to
pronounce it it's like
euphrates something like that river of
euphrates or something like that
it's going to dry up and it's currently
drying up and that in it
or around it near it will be revealed
like a pile a mountain of gold or a pile
of gold or something like that
um and these two are linked and they're
yet to come but everything else is
passed
possible
uh you know he did an amazing job
somebody said i'm
uh proving islam is true even 1400 years
ago with these prophecies
um one comment i want to make on the
verse about the sun and the moon
so these translators put in brackets
reflective
for the moon reflective light but the
arabic what it says
and it does make a differentiation right
it doesn't differ between the two it
says the sun is a burning lamp
right clearly it's the burning lamp it's
the source
where yeah whereas the moon is just a
light it just calls it a light
uh showing that they're not the same and
some scholars don't even interpret this
scientifically they just say this is
just in regards to how it looks
the this moon looks like a nice light
and the sun looks like a burning lamp
and so on and so forth but regardless um
this amongst many other scientific
miracles in the quran are basically
indisputable
um i agree man there's so many things
like we're not going to go into all of
these things because
we we could make a whole podcast series
not just an episode on these things
guys and girls but things from like
atomic weight to hydrogen to the speed
of light everything
was revealed in the quran i kid you not
it wasn't until later on that western
science and
philosophy and medicine caught up to
these things and coined these terms
yeah subhanallah i think one of the
bigger ones more recently is
uh discovery of the big bang and that
the universe is expanding because
there's a time in the time of the
communist that they thought the universe
was infinite
right and communists love this they love
this because it diminishes religion
um because if the universe is infinite
there's no need for a god
because the universe is the necessary
existence but
when the big bang theory or the big bang
model was kind of brought forth
it shows that the universe has a
beginning and it's expanding
and that's what the quran said 1400
years ago that
basically allah created the the heavens
and the earth or the the heavens and
he is expanding it basically he created
the universe and uh
he is expanding it so this amongst
others subhanallah
is more evidence but
you recently reverted masha'allah so
what would you say
was the main driving force or main
driving forces behind you
accepting islam
man my story is real weird
like i dude
i want to say it was about like 2000
[Music]
2013 maybe 2014
uh my sister's baby daddy had given me a
quran
it was a green covered quran and like
when he gave it to me
i looked at him because i i in my head i
was real ignorant at the time i was like
yo
isn't the cooldown for arabs and isn't
there cooldown for like
terrorists you know not not to cut the
algorithm here but uh
man i just didn't know i had all these
preconceived notions and
like when he gave that to me he's like
oh when you're ready
open it up and i was like dude
get out of here now i i left the book
bro
ignorantly i left the book but um you
know
i don't even know bro i lost touch with
him but i i mean from his actions
maybe not but then again like you can't
judge someone on their actions
you know so all i can say is that a lot
of guys who he was
and at some point dude like
it just kept coming back in my life but
like ignorantly
i was very closed off and guys i i have
a big
ego and i'll get on to that in a second
which why
like i love islam so much because
the fact that it makes me humble myself
and it makes me
uh submit myself to the creator and
makes
makes me put my ego aside and be able to
just
communicate better with people and have
better connections
but um i'll get to that in a second
right so it
i kept having kept having these uh
instances where someone would mention
the quran or they would mention islam
and
just ignorantly thinking ignorantly
seeing things i just kept brushing it
off brushing it off
and then i want to say about like maybe
a year
year and a half ago i was staying with
uh
my two buddies at this one place
and something told me like hey buy buy a
bible
buy a quran my bad and
put this in your your little library
because i was having this little like
bookshelf library with like arabic knife
and crystals it was real stupid to be
honest with you but
nonetheless there was
and like i had moments where i would be
like pooled
to read it but then like as i would
start reading it
my 80d would kick in and i would just
start doing something else
right and then it got to a point where i
had found out about
dopamine detoxing where all you do with
dopamine detoxing is you are
limiting the things that invoke or
evoke dopamine within you so it's like
entertainment music movies netflix
pornography
sex alcohol drugs all these things
you're limiting it and i was like you
know what
my life is pretty trash right now so let
me try this out and when i did that
dopamine detox i remember sitting in my
room
and i was just looking in my closet
and all i could see was the kudan and it
was weird it was just like
it was very pooling like just something
was pulling me to it
and every time i would look away i'd be
thinking about something like my eyes
would just
ver just revert right back to the quran
and like i can't even explain it to this
date
but of course bro still ignorant at that
time so i didn't think much of it
um fast forward several months later
i come back from new york from having a
surgery
and i remember i was feeling pretty down
man so i decided i was like okay i'm
gonna do a dopamine detox again
and as soon as i started doing dopamine
detox i'm sitting in this exact room
right here
actually sitting right there right there
and i remember i was just meditating and
i think i was like
it was the first day it was like 20 23
22 hours into the dopamine talks
and i felt the pool the same pool that i
felt in my room that day
i felt that pool but i felt it real
strong and i was like ah nah i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna read it because i'm doing
the dopamine detox
didn't read it second day comes i'm
sitting in the room
and it's like the same feeling overtakes
me but this time even stronger
and i was like yo like i have the book
like the quran
is right there like i should just read
it
but then again my mind was like nah nah
you're doing the doping detox don't do
it
so then again i didn't do it and then
the third day came and it was so strong
this time i was like you know what
forget it i'm just gonna read it it's
part of the journey it's not much dope i
mean whatever
i started reading the quran and i don't
know
what happened but i want to see like
the second day of reading it maybe the
third
uh right after i was done reading i
remember sitting down
having my eyes closed as i was just kind
of meditating on what i read and it's
like something
just clicked and when it clicked it was
like this
these waves that were just going through
my body and
it was the most craziest thing in this
world man like i can't even
if i had to explain it very simply
it was stronger than any drug that i had
ever taken
stronger than ecstasy stronger than
um alcohol stronger than shrooms
stronger than
acid stronger than weed and like i don't
condone any of these things but i'm just
saying like these are some of the things
that i have done
and it was a stronger feeling by
far than any of those things that i've
done and like from that moment i just
i kind of knew intuitively like that
this was it
this was the truth and now i remember
talking to fire
and he just kind of like give me some
more information about it and
like the more i got into it everything
just click kept clicking even more and
more so i was like
yeah this is it and i did my shahada
man subhanallah man i feel like one of
the best feelings is
like when you're learning about islam or
you're just going through life
and you just realize that like
everything's lining up perfectly like
islam was right islam was right it was
right it was right
all along and subhanallah it's either
you go through life
and you learn what you learn and then
you realize islam already taught
it or you learn islam but not really
know why
it's applied and then you go through
something in life and learn
i should have listened it's one of the
best feelings bro
man i have so much more to say too but
let me not let me not ball hog you
that's fair that's fair i mean if
there's anything worth mentioning
anything necessary then you know
obviously jump in let us know
it's all good stuff alhamdulillah but um
i feel like
it would be best to just present the
islamic claim in the islamic argument i
was actually working on a video all day
about um what is islam and then i ended
up with like the islamic claim
but basically islam just claims that
there's no god worthy of worship except
one god
and this one god created everything and
he sends prophets and messengers to call
people back to worshipping one god
this is a in line with christianity this
in line with uh
judaism and so on and so forth the
abrahamic religions basically
and islam says that the people of the
past they went astray they changed the
scripture they changed the theology and
we have instances
um where even jewish scribes changed the
like uh the uh theological aspects of
judaism
and we were christian scribes they
changed the literal text of the new
testament
and by the way the new testament is not
from god we don't believe it's from god
we believe god
gave jesus uh what we call the injil or
the gospel and then you have the gospel
according to mark
according to matthew according to luke
and john and then everything paul wrote
and and so on and so forth but that's
not from god as a whole
so 600 years later in
arabia comes a man in the prophet
muhammad or just muhammad sallallahu and
peace be upon him
and he gets revelation from god and he
is told to start preaching the people he
starts preaching
then he gains a few followers and over
time he gets kicked out of
mecca where he lived and then the people
basically
go to war with him even though he's in
another place it's a long story they end
up winning and they go back into mecca
they conquer it
then years go by 23 years of revelation
after that he passes away peace be upon
him and the torch so to speak is carried
by
his companions and then from there
in the middle of nowhere sprouts this
beautiful religion
that overtakes the persian empire the
roman empire
the byzantine empire and all like
literally just rules entire world
the entire world so brother i got some i
got something i gotta ask you
yeah all right so what you're saying
you know it kind of invoked this you
said that uh
the prophet muhammed peace be upon him
he was going
through all these things and you know he
he is known as
uh you could say a warlord you could say
something else
but he was a dom for lack of better
words
all right but he was also a very
peaceful dumb
meaning that like he was only trying to
spread the peace from the love
spread the message and someone asked me
actually a lot of people asked him but
someone very close to me
asked me he was a very good friend and
he
asked like why did i choose islam
and aside from what i had just said
earlier i've said that it's also a very
peaceful
religion and he kept going against it
saying that
i well the prophet and he didn't
he never set peace be upon him but i i
would say peace be upon him
he would say that the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him was uh
warlord and he was uh pretty much doing
unspeakable things
and how is that a peaceful religion
yeah so a lot of people just to
emphasize the question a lot of people
even say
oh weren't there violent questions uh
violent chapters in the quran
right where there are some of those and
some of these people lack
the like the context and the timing of
the revelation
so i guess you could have your your
inside inshallah
inshallah so basically a lot of people
misconstrue the history they take one
hadith out of context or a
mistranslation or one verse the quran
out of context
or they showed up just lie they should
have just liable to prophet peace be
upon him
so you have different instances that
people like to attack
for example chapter nine is one of the
most
violent chapters in the quran but if you
actually read the quran if you actually
read chapter 9 you'll see that it
literally starts off by saying
that the muslims entered a peace treaty
with some people
and then it goes on to say that the
people who broke the peace treaty
fight against them and expelled them
from the land
so the peace was not broken when the
muslims started fighting the
the peace was broken when the
non-muslims broke the peace treaty
when they broke the treaty so it's not
muslims going on the offensive
in a sense you could say they were going
offensive because they started the war
but it was only because
the these non-muslims broke the peace
treaty and in the same few verses it
says that but those who kept your treaty
with you
who kept the treaty with you keep the
treaty with them and in chapter 8
after the verse that says kill the
disbelievers it says but if they incline
towards peace
then make peace with them because the
natural state of islam is peace
it is to be peaceful but when you have
other people who don't believe in what
you believe in
attacking you are you supposed to sit
there and die no
you fight until you can establish peace
in the land again
so the whole reason they go to these
wars and fights and so on and so forth
is not just we want to dominate
everybody and take everything
it was this was actually never the case
it's because they were either
attacked first or there is plans to
attack them or attempt some left for the
prophet peace be upon him or
someone broke a peace treaty so on and
so forth so non-muslims
i would urge you every time you read a
verse that says kill the disbelievers
read a few verses before it and read a
few verses after it because most of the
time
it tells you what it is and if you
really can't find anything or if you're
so dull you can't piece it together
no offense then go to the scholar of
islam and they will tell you the
hadith the narrations of the prophet
peace be upon him that elaborate
on those very specific circumstances and
situations
and while we're at it bro why don't you
touch a little bit on
hadith authentication because a lot of
people are like
why should we believe these chain of
narration all that
all right so we are as certain of the
preservation of the
authentic hadith as we are about the
preservation of the quran because it was
transmitted
transmitted in the sim in the same way
basically trustworthy people who
memorized it
and taught it to trust with the people
who memorized it and so on and so forth
and that's making it very easy to
understand it and very
mild so to speak but it is a very
complex science the science of
hadith is very complex so we have a
hadith that
are basically authentic
and inauthentic so for example we have
mutawatur which means
it is without a doubt authentic and the
reason for this
is there are it's narrated by multiple
people who knew the prophet and heard it
from him
himself and there are multiple lines
chains of narrations from
uh a bunch of authentic people so the
possibility of them ganging together and
planning to lie about this
big thing for generations and
generations is very
unlikely so this is very
um authentic then you have stir in a
hadith that have one or two chains of
narration but it's broken somewhere
or it's missing a few narrators or the
narrator like someone named al kelby
is actually admitted himself to be a
liar we don't take a hadith
from those people so
this guy my bad brother
oh my bad i thought i took it off
there we go nice nice
but um that's basically it
um if a hadith is missing a narrator
or multiple narrators or the narrators
are not people who are trustworthy
then we don't accept the hadith but if
it is trustworthy
and the um the what's it called the text
of the hadith does not conjugate the
quran or it has not been changed or
something like that for example some
narrators have very weak minds
so they they're not taken as authentic
because they they're not trusted to even
remember
what the hadi said in the first place so
it is a very complex science
but we are very sure of the authentic
hadith because the people who compiled
it and who they
got the narration from and who they got
it from so on and so forth
right the hadith have a very strict
verification process
yes people's preconceived notions
yeah yeah as
i wouldn't say as important as the quran
but it's the next best thing because all
of the hadith together
show us what to do with the song with
the quran the quran is more so like
here's what it is hear the commandments
it doesn't say why it doesn't say here's
how you do it for example the quran
doesn't tell us at all how to pray
the prophet salam taught us how to pray
and it's from the hadith from
him that we realize how to pray and
learn how to pray right yeah
the hadith are very important
nonetheless and
as a salafi muslim um meaning like
one that just goes by the book by the
quran and hadith
that's all we follow there's no
innovation there's no modern
interpretations of that yeah
so now we talked about quran we talked
about hadith i want to make
when we talked about the islamic claim
that there is one god where they worship
his prophets and messengers with
uh revelation and scripture now i want
to talk about the quranic
argument the quranic claim so i'm going
to present four
arguments basically to prove that islam
is true
so firstly the quran says that had this
book been from anyone other than god you
would have founded it many
contradictions
so i challenge everybody to find one
contradiction where it says
one thing and then it says the complete
opposite and there's just no way to
reconcile it
this happens in you know other
scriptures i don't want to name any
but you'll find scripture where it says
that
about a very specific situation a very
particular event
like three people were there and then at
a very particular event
there were six people there these cannot
both be true
or if you want to say okay well one said
three but they were like there was
technically there was three there were
just more than three
whatever three is the number you can
pull from it in some cases it would say
it was one person and this was their
name and it was three people and these
were the names and they're just
completely different people no way to
reconcile it so i challenge people to
bring one contradiction from the quran
they won't be able to that's what we
talked about preservation quran said
that we have revealed the quran and that
we will preserve it
so this is god himself promising that it
will be preserved so if it's not
preserved it's not from god
i challenge you to bring evidence and
it's actually it's actually really funny
when non-muslims try and bring evidence
they bring the like the saddest saddest
arguments they'll have a manuscript
where a word is erased and something
else is written over it
and instead of saying that the scribe
made a mistake and he corrected himself
they'll say that no he decided to change
it
even though it lines up with our quran
today he decided to change it or
something like that
so very pathetic argument so i challenge
you guys to go and uh
find proof that it's not been preserved
and lastly um
contradiction preservation kind of
drawing the blank here
part of me there's two more because i
think you said there were four
yeah okay so there's prophecy i'll get
to that in allah i want to talk about
oh yeah bring one chapter like it the
quran came from a man prophet muhammad
peace be upon him who could not read or
write he was illiterate
but he produced the most linguistic
or linguistically speaking the most
elegant book it became the measuring
stick it became the ruler for the arabic
language
and they teach it in schools even like
coptic christian schools in egypt
they teach the quran as it's the most
eloquent form of arabic and it came from
a man 1400 years ago who cannot read or
write the quran says that
it literally says get all your men
together get everybody together
and produce just one chapter like it the
shortest chapter in the quran
is three verses i think 10 or 11 words
and it uses 31 or 30 or 31 literary
devices including prophecy and this is
surah al kaufar
the shortest one and they couldn't even
do that they were literal like literal
experts in poetry back then they
couldn't even produce one chapter
even close to the quran and there are
narrations of even the best of the poets
the best poet of the time literally
saying this is from god i have nothing
like i can't do anything against it so
there are those three and then there's
prophecies there are prophecies in the
quran
like a chapter about the romans that
says the um
the persians have been defeated wait
what are the persians the romans
was the persians have been defeated but
in three to nine years that bounced back
or was the opposite no i think it was
the former
okay yeah so the persians no i'm gonna
look it up man i don't wanna
get it wrong
this is very um important stuff we're
dealing with here
no room for errors so
quran i don't know you guys
why don't you tell them how you came
back to uh
islam because you you became
homophobe uh uh what's it called
homosexual for a little bit and then you
you saw that it wasn't
oh yeah
i owned the top called uh it was a
grinder
and uh that's how you know actually yeah
yeah yeah yeah i had set my radius
because you're in florida right
yeah my radius to unlimited because i
was i was going through a rough time in
my life
and that's when we met other right we'll
we'll
do that later bro well yeah we'll talk
about that later maybe
maybe we'll make that a patreon
exclusive
exclusive is that a true story nah no
the romans have been defeated
the romans have been defeated but in
three to nine years they will
basically they will come back and they
will defeat the persians this was a
prophecy at the time
and it came true i believe six or seven
years later
they gave up it gave circumstances it
gave a time frame and
it came true this is the quran 1400
years ago and there are sources outside
of islam that claim this as well that
the romans beat the persians
and it's actually a double prophecy
because it says that day
the believers will rejoice they'll be
happy basically so it's kind of like
okay the romans defeat the persians why
would they be happy about that
why is it a victory they have nothing to
do with either of them but that
battle where the the romans defeat the
persians
was the same day that the muslims
defeated quraysh and the people that
were coming to fight them in that first
battle
so that day the muslims were rejoicing
because they got to go back into mecca
basically
so this is actually a double prophecy
subhanallah and then we have what we
talked about before the prophecies of
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
things like um women will be clothed but
naked
i don't want to tell you go to a beach
and look but if you go to a beach and
look you'll see that
or even when they wear tight clothing
it's like it defines everything
so there's this uh shaykh hamza yusuf
actually narrates or he doesn't narrate
but he mentions in a narration that the
prophet they said
used this symbol when talking about
people will take a rock from their hip
and see what's going on back at home he
used this symbol this is like the
universe's
telephone basically yeah subhanallah
it's quite in-depth
and also he said he said that people
will be reclining in leather seats and
something that is moving
right so that's kind of like a car now
they're reclined in a leather seat of a
car
a nice rolls-royce
there's so many things that the quran
talks about and talked about
and we're just trying to get you guys
here before
that the sun is going to rise from the
west bro
when that day comes non-muslims muslims
everyone's going to submit
and we're just trying to do it sooner
than later but not just blind faith
we're trying to
i guess prove it because it is something
contrary to belief that can be proven
yeah so to take a viewer's stance on
this anonymous viewer's stance it's kind
of like hey you're saying all this stuff
you know how do i know you're telling
the truth fact check everything we've
said go factual
fact check the prophecies of the prophet
muhammad fact check the verses in the
quran
uh fact check the scientific miracles in
the quran you can go fast
check the fact this check fact chest
pack
yes check the facts i talk too much
but um yeah check the facts and see if
we're telling the truth or not
and dmos dm me with your concerns 100
man i've literally i've compiled all my
research of scientific medicals in the
quran
ranging from embryology medicine
genetics chemistry cosmology quantum
physics and i literally created a pdf
that if you guys want i will share this
with you
and just look at it this is it can't be
proven like
1400 years ago there's no way so look at
that like brother romney said look at
the prophecies not just the quranic
miracles look at
anything we talked about in terms of
truth
and try to find a new contradiction you
won't be able to
and inshallah just make an informed
decision
insha allah basically to summarize it i
we just gave you
four falsification tests these things
are falsifiable
they are provable they are testable
contradiction preservation prophecies
and bring one chapter like it the
eloquence of the quran
disprove what any any of these four
and if you can then only logically
speaking you would have to you would
have to agree that you
at the at the very least you have no
reason to disbelieve in this religion
no reason to and let's talk about
emotional skepticism but maybe we'll
talk about that later
hundred percent dude with my limitless
and
all other religions let me just get this
out there i can give you one to three
of these four things that you're
challenging me for almost any other
religion i know
but i can't with the song so actually
speaking logically speaking
it appeals to my mind and i don't want
to say this is a one-size-fits-all but
for me i categorize um the journey to
your iman and to strengthen it into the
beam in three categories the first guy
is born into islam or a disbeliever i
categorize it the same
as they don't have that conviction they
don't have that full belief
number two they come to a point where
it's like this takes a lot of work by
the way again from one to two
where they realize islam rationally
makes the most sense
they don't have the full conviction yet
they don't have that full spiritual
connection yet
but they realize it's at least more
interesting more intriguing than every
other religion
there's something odd about this one
there's something weird about this
i can like connect to it more and the
number three
is where it's like okay no full
conviction this is it
i want to say i also challenge people to
even look at other religions
because like i said qualifying islam is
not the only way
if you really really want and some of
some of the best
converts are people who research other
religions and they say that okay this
doesn't make sense that doesn't make
sense i don't believe in this i don't
believe in that
so on and so forth and then when they
get to islam they have no reason to
reject it so i challenge people to also
look at other religions look at you know
christianity judaism hinduism seek with
them
uh research them in depth and then
research islam as well
and then make your choice that was
wonderful
but yo quick question why do we call it
reverts and non-converts
so yeah in islam we believe that
everybody is born a muslim
and they're born believing in one god
alone when we say born muslim i mean
submitting to god believing in one god
alone
and when a baby comes out all they have
is their instincts
and you know what they've been given so
this is what a baby is born with
this what we call the fitra right the
innate instinct the natural
um uh the innate right or wrong
yeah yeah you can extend it to that but
i wouldn't
use that as like a guiding compass but
um yeah basically innate belief in god
and there was actually a study done at
oxford university where a doctor took a
bunch of kids
different ages different ethnicities
different backgrounds different
upbringings and asked them all
essentially if they believed in god or
higher power something like that and
they all said yes
every single one of them so this is
confirmed inductively speaking
scientifically speaking as well
uh but we believe everyone is born in as
a muslim believing in one god and then
they're either
put on islam or they're taught otherwise
so that's why we call it revert because
if they accept islam they're essentially
just coming back
to what they were born into
[Music]
yeah i go as far as to say that um if
you think about the question again like
why
islam logically speaking from what y'all
said
that islam is like rationally the one
that just makes the most sense
from a rational standpoint of you from a
logical standpoint of you
and guys like that's what it is we
function of what emotions
and logic and you know
a lot of different cultures a lot of
different religions a lot of different
philosophies
ideologies it all functions off some of
it might have
a little bit logic here some of it is
mostly emotion dominated but it's like
you look at the quran you look at islam
and it's all elijah yes there's emotion
for sure because like i go as far as to
say that you need to feel god
you know you can't just know god from
your rational mind you need to feel god
as well but it's like
the quran gives you all
the logic all the rational side where
it's like
you look at other forms when they're
trying to tell you
of a divine being they're trying to tell
you of the creator or
something of the sort and then they
can't really give you
uh all the rationale they can't give you
the logic
you're left with more questions
sometimes than when you entered it
yeah and what did you can't
like i i challenge you guys to ask any
question
to us and if not you know find some
scholar or anything
there's no question that islam doesn't
have an answer to
whether whereas other religions yeah i
can't say the same bro
not to throw shade of anything against
them but
again just bring it down
speaking about this let me play devil's
advocate
so we answered pretty much why islam
and why not christianity we answered to
an extent
why islam and why not judaism
so why islam
and why not new age
no age like atheism uh
dude i don't even know i'd say let's say
new age religion
because these people are over here
talking about the third eye
about um consciousness
about crystals about uh tarot card
readings
astrology and all this stuff
like they say they're woke and i'm
spiritual but i don't need to believe in
god
to be so um well i would
completely automatically disqualify them
if they don't even bring god into the
equation because like i'm trying to find
god i'm not trying to find your
consciousness buddy but um like
it's it's just funny they say god is is
the universe
that's a contradiction because the
universe is finite the universe began
god is infinite god does not have a
beginning many many issues with that
also the universe is made up of smaller
parts which make it
god is not made up of smaller parts he
would not be the necessary existence if
he
had things he relied on to be god um
that doesn't make any sense so
[Music]
um i find that to be i find these people
to have very pathetic
uh superficial ways of thinking to say
the least not not to throw shade not to
be offensive but
you're making you're literally i'm sorry
you're making things up as you go you're
making things up as you go
you don't have anything tangible
anything provable you just
you say things that kind of in a way
they resonate with people
who also think superficially
these people have found logical reasons
they're relying on their emotions
that have been logically yeah no and
they're
not gonna lie these people are more
susceptible to be influenced
which is why the next episode insha
allah when we talk about the war against
islam
i want to talk about how and inshallah
will do that but
these are mainly the people that the
west and this propaganda and the system
is brainwashing and confusing it's it's
making them feel like okay you know
it feels right to do this it feels
inhumane to not do this therefore let's
believe in it even though that's your
short-term gratification that's just
stroking your ego
making you feel good but it might not be
good for the next generation
youth whatever you want to say um dude i
feel
i feel like people who got into new age
new age religion is because they did not
have a
concrete path set out before them
like by their parents by their family
and i speak from experience man i speak
from experiences even though
even though i was catholic that was from
my mom's side my dad bro i don't know
what the he was and then like when my
mom got with this one guy
that you know i'm not gonna get into
detail but that guy made my life a
living hell
like dude that guy was christian and
he basically made us believe in like the
christian way
but he he believed in god so much yeah
he was abusing me for years and years on
this so it's like i always had the
question man like how can
you be christian how can you believe in
god and then you're over here abusing me
and doing all this stuff
so it's like to me i didn't have that
set path
and then that's what led me to like
atheism after
a whole bunch of other stuff and then it
led me into the new age and then when i
got into the new age bro
just like y'all are saying i was very
very impressionable i believed almost
everything
and i'm gonna be a hundred percent
honest with you guys i was making things
up as i went
and it's like anytime someone tried to
uh dispute
what i was saying anytime someone tried
to argue with what i was saying bro i
would be so irrational
because everything that i was coming
from had
no foundation it had no base no
structure
and it's like i would try to take
teachings and like different things from
like different religions like
hinduism buddhism uh i believe it's
taoism that's uh over in asia
like the in china and japan uh but i
might i might be
completely wrong but
yeah i was bro i was taking it from all
these things bro
and this it was just i was a dummy bro i
was a dummy when i was into this new age
religion stuff
not a lot i just want to get something
out there like i get it man the
the guy you were talking about
completely misrepresented his
you know what he was preaching um and a
lot of people might feel like that about
muslims today maybe they've had one bad
encounter with the muslim
maybe they look at the fox news
narrative but again
what we keep telling people is islam is
perfect muslims are not
yeah i agree with them a little bit
um before you even go in let me just
answer that real quick
i believe that 100 i believe that you
should not judge
the religion based on a person and the
whole point that i was trying to make
with uh my stepfather doing what he did
was not because i was judging
christianity based on his actions
i was just saying how like that in and
of itself
added on to the fact that there was no
concrete
structure as to what was the path that i
had to follow
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah but
go ahead romney
i just wanted to add before he moved on
um
how's the truth there's a question for
you guys at home has the truth
always made you feel good reality has it
always made you feel good
happy something or has it ever
disappointed you has the truth ever made
you upset
has reality ever disappointed you
personally
definitely fired you repeat that one
more time
has the truth the reality of life
whatever observable truth of reality
has it ever emotionally speaking
upset you hurt you you disliked it
something like that 100
men the true god 100 percent yeah subhan
allah
the truth hurts as they say right
so isn't this a reason why we should
remove emotion
from religion because if ever if a
religion is true
and we let it emotionally
or we emotionally look at it to the
point where we dislike it
emotionally and then dismiss it because
we
don't like it wouldn't this be an issue
because if it's still the truth it
doesn't matter whether i like it or not
it's the truth at the end of the day
i agree man it's just like parents you
might not always
feel good about what they're telling you
but they're always looking out for you i
say most parents because some parents
are messed up but
yeah yeah it's kind of long but
it's just it's essentially taking the
blue pill
yeah you know you're offered the reptil
the red pill is the truth
it's gonna hurt it's gonna hurt but
yeah ultimately it frees you
and if you don't want that you want to
stay stuck in
in your own little your little bubble
you take the blue pill
but like ultimately bro we all get hurt
in the end so you take the blue pill
you're still going to get hurt at some
point
yeah yeah but the blue filler never gets
easier
with the with the red pill it only gets
easier
the whole point of islam guys is to free
you from your attachments to the dunya
and to like free yourself and be
unattached so you can truly open up
and be non-needy and only connect with
the source
that's it there's no it's there's no
attachment of money
to women to any other
bad habit that you guys might have to
substances to anything worldly
that's it yeah let me piggyback off that
bro
so it's like this man you find out that
a girl's cheating
you take the red pill and you accept the
truth you accept the truth that she has
been cheating on you
you ended with her and from here on out
that's not to say that
another woman is never going to cheat on
you it's to say that
you are now open you are not awake to
the fact that okay
women are not angels you know
women can't cheat and in today's society
bro in the west
if the if the woman is not also
following god bro like also believing
and submitting to god bro
chances are she's probably gonna cheat
and it's like if you take the red pill
you understand
okay women are they might cheat all
right so next time a woman cheats on you
or next time she's throwing signals
that's like all right she's kind of
leaning that direction
you already know so it's like you only
become more aware you only become more
awake
and you you like you said it just gets
easier
over time because you don't get to the
point where a woman's going to take
advantage of you again but if you take
the
if you take the blue pill then you
you are ignorant to the fact that she
cheated on you so you're not accepting
it and then now she's gonna
cheat on you again and again and again
and again and chances are you're gonna
realize
that she's cheating on you again and
again and again and again but you're
gonna keep trying to brush it off
as if it's nothing and it's only going
to get harder and harder and harder till
one day
you're just going to break 100 percent
man she's one scholar she's going to do
it again history repeats itself
but that's not to say that there are
there aren't any good men
or women out there it's just it happens
today more than ever
but taking the red pill you get to
navigate the world
realistically not idealistically you
don't see things as you want it to be
emotionally like romney said
but logically as they are and oftentimes
it's when we too
strongly rely on our emotions that we
get cocked
yeah and the thing is is
with islam it doesn't neglect these
things right the quran
says that you love money people love
money they love an abundance of money
and it's true we do
it doesn't neglect that fact it's saying
that we shouldn't
we do but we shouldn't we should try and
stay away from it
we should try and be more charitable
though prophesy said the biggest fitnah
for a man
is a woman the biggest test for a man is
a woman and you can even flip this
around and say
one of the biggest tests for a woman
could be a man i'm not going to say it's
exactly the same
but it is up there of course and
it's not saying that you know these
things shouldn't exist they do
they do but we should try our best to
refrain from it and how do you do that
by submitting to god alone and obeying
islam obeying the commandments because
the prophet
he said a person would get married for
four things
wealth or beauty wealth status or
religion
he said if you want to be from the
winners then marry for religion
that doesn't mean your wife can't be
beautiful she can't be rich
she can't have you know a status in
society she can
but make sure religion is there and the
falsehood said
mary for manners character and deen
religion if you marry for her character
and you marry for her religion
then she has good character in religion
if she has good character and good
religion
chances of her cheating drop
significantly
but if you marry anyone who's pretty i
would say the chances of her cheating
actually go up
because a lot of women and let me throw
in men is
in there as well have a low regard for
someone
who they think they're better than so a
man will think i'm better than
this woman and then now i have the right
to cheat on her
and his own psyche he thinks who cares
and a woman who thinks her market value
is up here
will think why shouldn't i cheat on him
i'm up here and he's this this that
whatever he's a soy boy he's whatever
let me go with this man women women
today are more hypergamers than ever
this is this is facts yeah but they went
on average
on average but at the end of the day
don't let that shine you guys about
finding the right one for you at that
time
not to say there's just one
yeah that's another thing oh my god man
we'll talk about the uh
the difference between islam society and
all that next episode in sha allah
but um society has put forth a lot of
these ideas like
the idea of the soulmate the one and
only and it's kind of like
there are like a multitude of people out
there that you can have a long-lasting
healthy marriage with and you would be
happy with
maybe something you'd be happier with
some of you would be less happy with but
ultimately still be
happy with these people and you wouldn't
know the difference because you're not
with all these people
but the truth is you can be happy with
multiple people but as soon as you put
it in your head that there's only one
then as soon as you find someone you
think is the one you're gonna be like
that's it i'm with them forever and then
you're going to drop the ball and you're
going to mess up and become sloppy and
it's going to ruin everything
because you had this false premise this
false
idea that this is the one and that the
one
exists if
there's two things i could just debunk
that with islamically speaking
one allah talks about divorce in the
quran
that wouldn't have been there if there
was only the one and number two
can't be the one when there's four
i know man let's be honest man that's
why you're muslim
dude i'll be like that guy from nigeria
and have like 98 wives
that's haram by the way guys you can't
have nine
we'll talk about those things later
that's not yeah they're
yourself there is the one there is the
one then end it off by saying there is
the one god and i will worship him alone
because as soon as you say that about a
spousal partner or anything in life
you're putting that thing in the
position in your heart that god should
have
and when you do that you're messing
yourself up it's like putting the wrong
key
uh in in a keyhole it's not going to
open and it's just it's going to cause
more frustration in the long run
and you're never going to be able to
enter that place you want to that
enlightened state because a lot of
people try and find these things
to achieve gratification but it's not
proper gratification it's temporary
it's short-lived and as allah says in
the quran that this life is nothing but
temporary delusion
and enjoyment you don't want that you
want something that's everlasting
and what does allah say he says in the
quran that indeed in my remembrance with
remembering me
the hearts will find ease how many times
have you been in a hardship and you
called out to allah you called up to god
asking for something
and just asking god made you feel better
and then let alone when he answers it
and you're in a better situation
how many of us actually stay on that
path of thanking god
and how many of us revert back to our
old selves and become
comfortable idol and forget about god so
these are just you know this is just
some food for thought
um
this was a solid episode you guys have
anything else
you want to talk about before we wrap it
up
on him all right then guys with that
being said
tune in for the next video yes sir
make sure you guys like subscribe
and share